olá bom dia é hoje vou falar um
pouquinho de educação internet e vídeos
é nada mais do que isso acho que as
pessoas esperam que eu falasse isso não
é uma receita de bolo aqui mas eu queria
falar primeiro de uma característica
inerente ao ser humano acho que nós
somos seres sociais
ninguém gosta de ver sozinho na sua casa
isolado
se gosta né é porque alguma coisa de
errado aí e eu como todo ser humano toda
vez que eu vi alguma coisa interessante
encontravam coisa interessante algum
livro em alguma revista em na tv na
internet eu queria compartilhar com meus
amigos eu queria falar dessa caramba
isso aqui é muito bom mas as pessoas
precisam saber disso
então acredito que essa característica
de querer compartilhar de querer ensinar
de querer passar coisas boas seja uma
característica do ser humano todo mundo
tem isso naturalmente você já nasce com
isso e bem passar conhecimento é uma
característica inerente ao ser humano
ok e muitas vezes descobria coisas
interessantes para ser passadas mas aí
vem assim a seguinte questão com o
passado como eu posso passar isso para
os meus amigos como eu posso passar isso
de maneira eficiente para eles
aí eu pensei pensei na época já existia
internet obviamente e aí eu tinha uma
brilhante idéia brilhante idéia blog né
acho que todo mundo já chegou a ter um
blog na vida ou pensou em t1 e já
acessou o que eu faço em carambeí
eu não preciso mais explica um por um
uma coisa tão interessante que eu tenho
um papel impresso fácil mas só que legal
dá uma lida pra dar uma lida com muita
interessantes aqui olha só que legal
explica a mesma coisa contou a mesma
história toda hora repetia
eu falei assim cara blog é muito legal
e aqui tá mais ou menos como é que era o
meu blog
ele ainda existe e olhando assim blog
será que é realmente tão interessante
assim infelizmente eu tive um feedback
dos amigos e não era muito interessante
blog pessoal na unidade já jovens é
tetra
e aí eu percebi algumas coisas eles não
são muito atraentes
meu público acha legal né porque você
consegue mensurar quantas visitas têm o
seu blog e era muito baixo era muito
baixo acho que só eu acessava eli sabiá
aí eu pensei em ser melhor vacina não
tem que ter uma maneira mais eficiente e
poder compartilhar suas idéias haiti uma
idéia brilhante com essa idéia
vídeos aí sim né vídeos né e sim vídeos
porque vídeos eles são mais didáticos
são mais dinâmicos e são mais
interessantes né aí foi só sucesso
bombom fez sucesso aí vi muito dinheiro
e fama muita fama e muitas outras coisas
e eu fiquei milionário me aposentei
é isso aí galera falou valeu não não
obviamente que não dessa experiência
toda eu pude tirar algumas coisas
interessantes e é por isso que estou
aqui né todo mundo sabe que educação é é
muito importante para qualquer país ea
gente sofre de um problema forte
educação aqui no brasil isso é noite
isso não é novidade pra ninguém e
aparentemente a ajuda do governo não
parece tão suficiente pra poder
realmente fazer grande diferença grande
para o nosso país a gente ainda tem
demanda a gente tem deficiência da
educação
e aí saí às duas questões o que nós
podemos fazer por onde e mesmo se a
gente querer fazer alguma coisa pela
educação o que a gente pode fazer por é
por onde pode começar já existem muitas
questões pode levantar e aí surge uma
outra idéia
internet internet é o caminho porque a
internet porque a internet tão
interessante assim quase metade da
população brasileira consegue é têm
acesso à internet alguma forma ou seja
isso já é um número relativamente grande
de pessoas que a gente pode alcançar
usando sua internet aqui no brasil né
então a gente pode usar a internet como
canal de distribuição de conhecimento
quase metade da população brasil esse
número tende a crescer sempre mais e
mais
acredito seja muito interessante isso e
ao contrário do mundo real que a gente
vive atualmente é que é movido pela mata
pelo materialismo pé pelo objeto por
exemplo se você dá uma coisa uma pessoa
você acaba perdendo essa coisa e quando
recebe a pessoa acaba perdendo na
internet isso é totalmente diferente
quando você começa a compartilhar uma
coisa pra pessoa não existe uma
subtração como existe no mundo material
o simplesmente multiplica essas coisas
literalmente com mágicas ao que é
impossível fazer nosso plano físico e aí
perguntam beleza ou vamos à internet é
muito bonito tudo mundo conectado
mas qual a melhor forma de estudar
internet vídeos mais de 80% das pessoas
que acessam a internet elas utilizam
vídeos elas acessam vídeos as procuram o
conteúdo de vídeos
então se a educação problema nós podemos
ajudar
utilizando os vídeos na internet e dessa
forma que consegue fazer alguma
diferença sim eu acredito mas há muitos
muitos vão dizer ah mas existem
documentários em vídeo aulas
tem muita coisa na internet isso já não
é novidade para muita gente também
mas vídeo-aula mais internet normalmente
costuma ser o que é chato né
costuma ser chato infelizmente é muito
chato
a gente precisa quebrar os paradigmas
então é a primeira coisa a fazer é
pensar nas pessoas que acessam a
internet e que assistem vídeos na
internet porque essas pessoas acessam a
internet com o objetivo delas entram na
rede e assistem aos vídeos
será que é pra ver isso aqui eu acho que
não né nossa quer chegar em casa ligar
meu computador acessá-la e aprender
física quântica acho que é meio difícil
né os alunos quererem ter uma tem uma
força assim extraordinária vindo do além
da crê assistir uma aula dessas aqui não
não querem ver essas coisas
especificamente não quer ter esse
sentimento de sala de aula as pessoas já
têm nas suas vidas e acesso à internet
não pra ter uma experiência de novo de
sala de aula em casa e o que normalmente
encontra a internet
exatamente isso que vocês estão vendo e
bem a minha história na internet
eu tive que passar por isso também né
eu toquei várias vezes a linguagem e no
comecinho dos meus vídeos adivinha como
é que era que não fazia tão não fazemos
nenhum sincero como era formado no vídeo
desastre né não dizer eu estava
exatamente o que as pessoas não queriam
assistir à internet e não querem ver o
quadro branco o professor e ele
escrevendo coisas e fica falando né
mas não procuram isso vamos quebrar os
paradigmas de a gente vê atualmente
professores na sala de aula que quebram
paradigmas
ele consegue mais a atenção dos alunos
fazem piadas e interage com os alunos
trazem materiais novos produtos para os
alunos em sala de aula eles interagem de
forma diferente com os alunos não da
metodologia tradicional como a gente viu
aqui no novas palestras
então a gente possa quebrar esse
paradigma
também nos vídeos mas tem que descobrir
que a internet que a linguagem do vídeo
é muito mais rica mas pode realmente
colocar muito mais coisas nesses vídeos
não pode se limitar simplesmente a sala
de aula do passado e é claro né eu
falando aqui isso não entende
absolutamente nada beleza denis
a gente quer alguns exemplos e eu tenho
alguns exemplos aqui que eu fiz um
montagem e eu acho que são muito
interessantes que quer um pouquinho esse
paradigma que as pessoas tende a
acreditar vídeo-aula educação vídeo na
educação é na internet tem de ser sala
de aula sobre as ppp
é bom também para mim o futebol aqui ao
dizer na verdade o número vai encarar o
site napster
o
a união ficou né
existe melhor executivo da abiove
onézimo espanhol havia lutas pelo paraná
banco espanhol é o enterro da mãe
defende nati senhor está soando este é
um ano muito quietinho não anda
direitinho o inter quer fire whip
escrito vai conseguir isso daqui nem de
semana são paulo tem no território muito
amplas manifestou o brasil am
já o próximo ano obviamente tem um
exemplo também de vídeo e algumas
pessoas até acham que jogando lixo na
rua estão aumentando a oportunidade de
emprego dos varredores mas o que você
acha alguém que esse incêndio só para
dar mais emprego para os bombeiros
ou alguém solta criminosos para dar mais
emprego para os policiais
não é assim que as coisas funcionam não
é mesmo
então como as coisas funcionam bem em
alguns exemplos interessantes de como a
gente pode usar uma outra linguagem para
abordar assuntos normalmente chatos para
as pessoas que assistem à internet que
assistem vídeos na internet
às vezes a gente sofre alguns problemas
né
a internet pode facilmente de sair com
muitas coisas mas pode ser um vídeo e aí
aparece a mensagem de um amigo né uma
atualização de alguma coisa ea pessoa
simplesmente perde atenção como a gente
pode resolver esse tipo de problema
a gente precisa de uma estruturação
interessante para o vídeo é preciso
integrar as pessoas a levantar questões
sempre com fatos recentes não é só
porque você ensina matemática que você
precisa sempre usar a mesma metodologia
pode levantar questões atuais que têm a
ver com a sua matéria para poder montar
o seu vídeo isso é novidade na sala de
aula
o vídeo também é muito mais interessante
muito mais rico se você colocar coisas
atuais e interessantes
sem contar que isso também aumenta a
relevância de busca na internet né fatos
recentes e eu coloco a seguinte questão
pra vocês
você assistir um filme com a mesma
emoção se eu soubesse o final
aqui no brasil não existe nada mais
chato que alguém falar o final do filme
e acho que você nem é você não fica só
desanimado em assistir um filme já sabe
o final
o sinebahia estimado do filme mesmo as
novelas ou seriados têm uma estrutura
tão interessante
eles começam levantando questões
levantando porque e antes de acabar o
primeiro episódio ele coloca uma dúvida
sempre com o impacto a pessoa assim
caramba vou ter que esperar mais uma
semana para poder assistir e essas
coisas que prende a atenção então essa
arma e suspense é a chave para os seus
vídeos
você sempre tem que levantar isso pra
prender as pessoas para este uma ligação
para as pessoas não saírem de nenhum
jeito de assistir seus vídeos
outra coisa que as pessoas perguntam é
porque não tem recurso não tem
habilidade como é que eu vou fazer os
vídeos bem antigamente era muito difícil
para tirar uma foto só para tirar uma
foto só de muito mais equipamento era um
processo muito mal humorado coisa que
hoje em dia já não é mais só para se ter
uma idéia a câmera que usava para
começar a fazer os meus vídeos foi essa
aqui é incrível câmera que tem 4.1
megapixels
acredito que o celular que vocês tenham
bolsa agora tem mais resolução do que
essa câmera que usava no começo né
então eu acho que não tem uma desculpa e
sempre aproveite a oportunidade e
aproveitar a oportunidade para exercer
sua criatividade
então se você tem alguma dificuldade de
edição de vídeo de filmar qualquer coisa
assim
enfrente desafios
não desista né eu mesmo meus vídeos eu
recordava papel eu desenhava se não eu
vou desenhar no papel é todo manual não
sabia nós não sei fazer animação 3d não
sei fazer nem se mexendo para o poste
direito aqui e tá fazendo não vou
desenhar então se dizia um boneco de
palito é exatamente isso que nos bancos
de palito e rasgava esses papéis e
começa a fotografar
eu falei não vou gravar a voz em cima já
fica mais legal
e mesmo se eu conseguir fazer os vídeos
e esse pode aproveitar até os seus
alunos para participarem também nas suas
produções de vídeos e acredito que eles
tenham eles têm muitas idéias
interessantes pra vocês e eu acho que
vai ser um tempo muito bem aproveitado
porque cada hora gasta para gravar um
minuto do de um vídeo na internet chama
muita atenção das pessoas
essa hora com certeza vai ser compensada
vai ser multiplicada pelo número de
visualizações vai ter pelo retorno que
vai ter pelo pela pela transmissão de
conhecimento que você vai poder alcançar
na internet um público atual e por fim
que deixará seguinte é seguinte citação
caso muito interessante
milhares tiveram as podem ser acesas de
uma única vela ea vida da vela não será
encurtada felicidade nunca diminui ao
ser compartilhada
e é isso gente obrigado